[Music]
the crimes of Grindelwald is upon us and
we couldn't be more excited we decided
to do some digging and we found some
pretty amazing similarities between the
two greatest dark wizards stay tuned to
learn just why they're so evil don't
forget to hit that notification bell to
never miss another video
and be sure to check out our community
section for even more fun now let's
check out some parallels between
Grindelwald and Voldemort powerful AF
okay let's start with a pretty easy
similarity most have notice well you've
probably only noticed it if you paid a
lot of attention to Harry Potter but
since the entire franchise has so many
mind-blowing moments many totally forget
about Grindelwald story the crimes of
Grindelwald will most likely refresh
your memory but hopefully this video
will do that too so the very first
parallel between the two is their power
we know that Dumbledore thinks
Grindelwald was more skilled during
their battle but we also know that both
Grindelwald and Baltimore two were
considered to be the most powerful
wizards of all times
we'll go into more depth about their
approaches when it comes to their power
in just a few minutes it's definitely
clear that these two are pretty strong
and it does make you wonder what other
similarities they have with each other
back when Dumbledore showed Harry his
memory of meeting Tom Riddle Harry asked
an interesting question he asked his
headmaster if he knew he was meeting the
most dangerous Wizard of all time well
Dumbledore said no but what if he said
no because he actually met Grindelwald
who was equally if not even more
powerful from this day forth you put
your faith connection to Dumbledore
so let's dive deeper into Grindelwald
and Voldemort's connection to Dumbledore
the truth is even though they're both
powerful AF they're actually still not
as powerful as Dumbledore let's be
honest he's pretty much the best wizard
there is as it was implied in the books
Albus was actually in love with
Grindelwald so if you think about it
it's very hard to be in love and still
think strategically when you're battling
that person right during their battle
Grindelwald was also using the Elder
Wand which
is the most powerful how could he
possibly lose well it's quite simple
Dumbledore's just that strong Voldemort
also struggled against Albus sure
Dumbledore wasn't in love with Baldy so
there was nothing holding him back for
fully attacking but Voldemort and
Dumbledore actually have very similar
dueling abilities as we've seen in the
books and yet Voldemort also lost to
Hogwarts best headmaster let's be honest
Dumbledore is unbeatable and even the
darkest Wizards know that considering
that Dumbledore Voldemort and
Grindelwald are all still way more
powerful than any other wizards you
might know the only difference is
Dumbledore uses powers for good not evil
sacred 28 let's talk about sacred 28
it's one of those things you won't
really learn unless you spend a lot of
time on Potter more but how could you
not when it gives us so much information
about the Wizarding World you can find
some pretty amazing stuff like the info
about the sacred 28 this dates back to
the 1930s or 1940s when an anonymous
publication shocked the Wizarding World
it talked about giving priority to the
truly pureblood families we have seen
how some of the Dark Wizard families
feel about non pure Bloods
well this behavior dates way back all of
the sacred 28 members were completely
embraced by Walda Mort who would make
them his followers but as it turns out
some of them were also Grindelwald
followers one of them was vin de rozier
and we'll be finding more about her in
the crimes of Grindelwald movie although
we know Voldemort and Grindelwald are
quite different from one another they're
actually still the same after all they
were both idolized by the same people
that thought having pure blood is the
way to go you can take across oh you
don't look a day over 375
Elder Wand the Elder Wand is just one of
those things that makes the Harry Potter
series absolutely amazing can you
imagine owning the most powerful wand in
the world according to the tale of three
brothers the wand was created by Death
himself well as it turns out both
Grindelwald
and the Voldemort owns the Elder Wand at
some point well sort of Grindelwald was
actually the owner and he got the ones
by breaking into the wands maker shop
since wand maker Grigorovich had the
wand the time Grindelwald had to claim
it to become the owner the wand was the
start of the utter terror and that's
precisely what Voldemort was after even
Ollivander knew that the Dark Lord
wanted the Elder Wand because it would
make him completely invulnerable so it's
no wonder he went after the one by then
the Elder Wand was in possession of
Dumbledore and Voldemort had no idea
that Draco became his owner after Albus
passed ball des morts did use the Elder
Wand at some points but unlike
Grindelwald he was never the owner so
judging by the whole situation Baldy
kind of idolized Grindelwald and didn t
mind games isn't it scary just how much
they both want to dominate the world
they're both so obsessed with purebloods
and the need to cause terror but
Grindelwald and Voldemort's had another
connection they both realized they had
to use certain mind games and mental
powers in order to succeed in their
mission Grindelwald actually held a lot
of secret powers which is exactly why he
became so powerful for example from the
fantastic beasts movie we know that
Grindelwald is actually an amazing seer
he can basically see the future which is
definitely coming in handy in many ways
but of course Grindelwald used a lot of
his powers for bad things instead of
good things being able to predict
people's moves is the ultimate way of
eventually dominating them and as we
know Valda more it's pretty much wanted
to make himself immortal and become
powerful in that way both at the
wizard's had a loyal following that
basically did everything they asked it's
actually scary just what they are
capable of doing isn't it on the other
hand Voldemort wasn't really a seer but
he did use other powers to make sure his
dominance remains safe for example he
had to learn aquaman see to stop Harry
from entering into his mind which one is
cooler to you occupancy or being a seer
let us know in the comments here to get
a loan open
bakery yes what are the odds of that
showing respect a Reddit user that was
Fred actually shared a pretty cool
theory on another connection between
Voldemort and Grindelwald we know that
throughout the Harry Potter series vol
de Mort is addressed in all sorts of
ways Death Eaters call him my Lord Harry
actually calls him riddle and Dumbledore
calls him Tom but there's only one
character that called baltimore's by his
dark wizard name yep the reddit users
states that Grindelwald is the only one
that ever called him Valda Mort if you
think about it Tom Riddle came up with
the name to inspire fear and reverence
he absolutely loves it when people fear
his name when Harry and Dumbledore use
his real name they are actually reducing
him to a mere mortal man and let's be
honest who would want that but
Grindelwald doesn't really do that
he's calling Baltimore's by the name
Baltimore chose for himself we know he
doesn't fear him but he also doesn't
ignore of all des morts reputation when
Grindelwald told Baldy to end his life
and used his Villa name did he actually
show respect he definitely didn't ignore
it like others of course all we got from
Grindelwald was one short sentence but
it's pretty cool to look at it from that
perspective Friedan's theory
reddit user kicks whiz seems to think
that there's another secret connection
between Grindelwald and Voldemort's the
reddit user explains that obscure you
will play an important part as we know
Grindelwald found credence so what if
Grindelwald uses credence to influence
tom riddle to continue his work in the
first fantastic beasts movie Grindelwald
explained his vision which talked about
a child with immense power this child
wasn't older than 10 years old we later
found out that he was actually referring
to credence but what if he's actually
referring to Tom Riddle and the child
he's referring to hasn't been born yet
the movie takes place in 1926 and that's
the year when Tom Riddle was just in the
womb so he would still fit Grindelwald
prediction of being under 10 years old
Grindelwald also mentioned that this
child is in close proximity to Creedence
his mother what if he was talking about
Creedence his biological mother who was
pregnant with Tom Riddle we know nothing
about her but what if Grindelwald
actually talked about Tom Riddle and Tom
is actually related to Creedence now
that would be a parallel no one
suspected influence on Tom Riddle Reddit
user
Wingardium underscore samosa discusses
the possibilities of Grindelwald having
an influence on Tom Riddle think about
it the vital duel is set in 1945 we know
that Tom opened the Chamber of Secrets
in 1942 when Grindelwald started his
dark arts mission this user seems to
think that Grindelwald could have an
indirect influence on Tom during his
time at Hogwarts after all people were
definitely aware of Grindelwald reign
right and since he had supporters back
then what if tom was just one of those
supporters he saw what Grindelwald was
doing and he decided to follow his lead
his interest in dark magic led him to
opening the Chamber of Secrets and you
could say that the rest is history
we know that baldemar it has always been
an intense kid who's very interested in
dark stuff he must have gotten
inspiration for his future actions
somewhere right
some Harry Potter fans are arguing that
Tom's Drive just came from him because
he's Tom but it could definitely be
possible that young Tom Riddle would
actually be totally inspired by what
Grindelwald was doing which is pretty
twisted if you think about it because
Grindelwald really wasn't doing anything
good Horcruxes
here's another parallel to consider of
course this one is just a theory but if
you think about making sense of
everything you know about these two
wizards it kind of works
we all know that Horcrux is are really
dark magic like really dark splitting
your soul into different pieces is
definitely not a pleasant experience
there's a reason why people can't even
obtain information about Horcruxes
but could Grindelwald have created a
Horcrux too we know he was too busy
being totally obsessed with Deathly
Hallows but considering all the
similarities between Baltimore two and
Grindelwald if the Horcruxes could
definitely be a connection to some vans
argue that grinned
had a slightly more moral code when it
came to death but we have a feeling
Grindelwald definitely knew about
Horcruxes after all he was a powerful
wizard how could he not know what
Horcruxes were let's not forget his
cierk abilities wouldn't he be able to
predict of all des Morts Horcruxes it
was definitely something the eye could
have picked up on and as we know he was
a talented seer JK Rowling also revealed
that Grindelwald was an da clemens which
means he could definitely see what Baldy
was up to sociopaths the subject to
whether Voldemort was actually a
sociopath has been discussed greatly but
is the statement true could these
powerful dark wizards actually have a
lot more in common than we think well it
looks like the usual characteristics of
a sociopath would mean that Valda Mort
definitely doesn't fit into that
category
since his crimes are more structured and
cold-blooded but he could definitely fit
into the description of a psychopath
Grindelwald on the other hand could sort
of fit the sociopath description
especially since although he was
powerful his crimes seemed just a bit
more erratic and unstructured the way
Grindelwald treats credence implies his
total lack of empathy and we know that
neither Voldemort or Grindelwald were
empathetic although it's hard to analyze
fictional characters Valda Mort and
Grindelwald could very easily fit in the
sociopathic and psychopathic models
because let's be honest you have to be
in a certain state of mind to go through
anything these two went through what do
you think does the evil and both come
from a much more complex place or are
they just simply evil and possibly
inspired by one another let's debate in
the comments below and that's it for our
video don't forget to subscribe to the
things for more videos like this one
thanks for watching and see you next
time
[Music]